[Music]
it's loud
it's raucous and it's back the notting
hill carnival reclaimed its place as one
of london's most renowned festivities
it's a celebration of afro-caribbean
culture
started as a children's event by local
communities to ease racial tensions in
london during the 1960s the carnival has
come to embody the city's diversity
after being forced online as a result of
the pandemic it's a welcome return for
those who missed it
oh my god it feels amazing we've been
waiting like three years for this yeah
three years
but um yeah it's gonna be fun honestly
amazing like i'm happy to do that
because i feel like it is home i guess
yeah i love it i missed it man
yeah it's overdue it's like two years we
missed so yeah it's overdue man i'm
happy
but it's not only the pandemic that's
had an effect
inflation and the rising price of goods
from sequins to feathers have put
pressure on creatives who play a crucial
part in making the flamboyant costumes
economical situation now everyone
doesn't have money or don't want to
spend money because they're not sure
what they're going to meet so there's a
lot of issues around
this year's
what we call going on the road you know
after a two-year hiatus the organizers
have said it has been a challenge to
bring together europe's largest street
party nevertheless they're back and it's
time now to celebrate all the efforts of
the organizations and the people who are
taking part here
people have been working so hard over
the years looking forward to this with
the costumes the planning the
organization of it all it's a huge as
you can imagine a huge organizational
task to put on one of the most iconic
community-led festivals on the planet
[Music]
a welcome return for a well-loved street
party sonia gallego al jazeera london